[Music]
[Music]
yo sno-cone oh yes hyperactive little
reindeer
[Music]
my name is Noelle Kringle Martin
princess my partridge in a pear tree
underwear needs washing
oh well then my Christmas wish has been
granted Christmas runs in my family
my dad was Santa and now it's my brother
Nick's turn to wear the hat stocking
full of Kolff ever received one he saved
a kitten from a tree nice well your
brother I'd be ready by Christmas of
course he's a creme sometimes I dream
about getting out well you can't be
Santa if you're having a nervous
breakdown you it'll get away for the
weekend the first time in 2,000 years
Santa has disappeared I just said he
should take the weekend off we must have
a new center Gabriel Kringle me I'm in
the tech department and loving it what
about a rescue mission do you mind
telling me what you're doing I'm going
to get my brother and you're coming with
me
stay right where you are we are looking
for Santa Claus
you don't tell anybody who you are where
are you think I'm gonna tie a rope or or
you came from sir it's a privilege to
wear that suit put some pants on so
Lobby Christmas Eve has less than 48
hours away this could be the perfect
time to start an online delivery
platform gotta find Santa thousands
appears to be of jingle bells until
they're poised and we must make sure
nothing changes that I like your pants
they're jolly they're yoga pants like
yours these are my yogurt pants and no
yoga pants I love yogurt pants don't
want facing reindeer please wow that's a
big deal in here
[Music]